hey
hello hello hello hello
we've made it to the middle of the week
all right good afternoon everybody
so today we announced that uh President
Biden will travel next week to the
United Kingdom in Ireland he will head
first to travel to Belfast that'll be
his first step stop where he will Mark
the tremendous progress since the
signing of the Belfast Good Friday
agreement 25 years ago and underscore
the Readiness of the United States to
support Northern Ireland's vast economic
potential to the benefit of all
communities next the president will
travel to Ireland where he will discuss
our close cooperation on the full range
of shared Global challenges
he will also hold various engagements
including Dublin County louth and County
Mayo and and celebrate the Deep historic
ties that link our countries and people
we will have more information on this
trip to announce soon and uh finally I
want to wish a happy Passover to Jewish
Americans and communities across the
country who will gather around the Seder
table tonight as the president said
today Passover is more than just
recounting of the past it reminds us of
our moral obligation of State clearly
and forcefully that anti-Semitism must
stop
Passover is also a story of redemption
resilience and unity a story of people
coming together with a shared faith and
a shared people for a better tomorrow
with that Zeke you want to kick us off
um thank you um first off here about
Passover president this morning a
references anti-Semitism strategy yeah
uh Doug uh some gentleman has talked
about as well when does he actually want
to see that strategy released so don't
have a timeline for the strategy on when
we would want to see that moving forward
but clearly the president has been very
vocal on the anti-Semitism that we have
seen across the country the violence and
so of course we're going to continue to
speak to that as I just did just now as
the president did uh clearly in his
statement just don't have any update on
the particular on the specific strategy
we've seen additional uh devastating
tornadoes and storms
what the last several days
there's a present plan to travel to
Arkansas is there additional College you
can read out and what's the status of
federal support for the Target
communities so don't have an update on
any travel that the president's going to
be making I can say Federal teams
continue to work closely with state and
local officials to get impacted
communities the support they need
President Biden has been in touch with
leaders across the the impact it states
we've got hundreds of FEMA Personnel on
the ground that includes over 400 female
Personnel in Mississippi over 120 FEMA
Personnel in Arkansas they're surveying
damage assisting with recovery efforts
and More in Mississippi for example FEMA
has distributed more than two million
dollars in individual assistance and
we're committed to supporting impacted
communities as long as it takes of
course this is something that
unfortunately the president has had to
deal with when it comes to these type of
extreme weather during his first two
years of administration so he takes this
very seriously I just don't have
anything to share on travel but clearly
FEMA's on the ground doing and other
government officials entities are on the
ground doing everything that we can to
support the the citizens of these very
of these two states in particular and
just uh one last one on a different
topic um the attacks on the uh on the
prosecutor in New York on the judge in
New York in the in the Trump case uh
some directed by the president as
criticism from the Mexican president uh
of
prosecution uh I understand you
yesterday was well covered that you
don't want to talk about specifically
speak to criticism or attacks on the
Judiciary on the judicial system and the
nation's you know
systems I totally understand the
question and I'll just so that I'm on
the record per usual I'm not going to
speak to an ongoing case and I've been
we've been very consistent and very uh
prudent about that so we're going to
continue to leave that there but more
broadly of course and you've heard me
say this you've heard the president say
this many times we we condemn any type
of attacks on any judge that uh any uh
or our Judicial System uh that we have
seen over the last two years in
particular as the president has been in
office but again I'm not going to speak
to the case specifically but that is
something that we definitely condemn
one more on that topic can you just
confirm or tell us how the president was
informed of the charges against his
predecessor was he briefed on this do
you mean uh oh do you mean yesterday
would they what so look look the
president
um uh clearly and I said the president I
said this yesterday the president's
focus is on the American people that's
going to continue to be his Focus uh he
uh as as he was last week when uh when
the announcement was made uh of the uh
of uh of an indictment uh he was of
course a brief by by the his senior
members of his staff uh just like as we
we all found out you all learned through
uh through uh reports uh the media
reporting and that's all I have I don't
have anything more to share on that and
on the meeting between uh house Speaker
McCarthy and the Taiwanese president has
the U.S seen any signs that China could
be preparing some kind of response to
this meeting you know any evidence that
they could launch any kind of military
drills like they did Around Speaker
policies I'm just going to be very uh
I'm just going to repeat what secretary
blinken said as you you all heard him
moments ago when he did his press Avail
uh in uh in Belfast Belgium I'm part of
me in Brussels was confusing with the
top of with the president going to
Ireland and the UK he was very very
clear and we've been very clear we have
said there is no reason for Beijing to
turn this trash to this Transit into uh
into something that is used as a pretext
to overreact we've been very clear about
that this is something uh when you look
at this the transit that the the
president of Taiwan is doing this is
something that's been part of a long
tradition a long U.S tradition and so
again we just do not see there should
not be a reason for the PCR to uh to
overreact here
one quick one on the trip to Ireland in
the past the president has taken members
of several generations of his family
with him when he's made similar trips uh
can you discuss is anybody else going to
be coming along we'll have more to share
don't have anything specific on who if
there are going to be members of his
family attending uh the trip next week
but we'll certainly have more to share
as we get closer to the day
is he going to retrace his family Roots
there why is personally important for
him to go on display yeah just to give
you a little bit more uh so again we'll
have more in the coming days look the
president is eager I actually had a
conversation with him this morning about
this particular trip he's eager to visit
the United Kingdom and Ireland two
Nations whom we have close ties to uh he
as I mentioned will have a series of
engagements Belfast and Dublin and
County louth and County Mayo but as I I
as um you know as I mentioned look he's
looking forward to this the president is
going to be highlighting as you talk
about his family how his family history
is part of that larger shared history
between us and Ireland waves of Irish
immigrants helped shape America's Spirit
of freedom and of our drive for
Independence which launched an
irrevocable friendship between our two
countries so yes that part of the trip
where it connects to his family is going
to be incredibly important to him but
also the broader uh the broader
irish-american Community as well as we
talk about immigrants as we talk about
how this country was created so he is um
uh he's Inc he is definitely looking
forward to this trip
on the jet ceiling definitely interested
if you have any updates to share
conversations that have happened
including our staff level but more
specifically is the White House open to
a short-term increase at this at this
what I can say is what we've been saying
for for months now for weeks uh now
which is we believe that the debt
ceiling should be dealt with in a way
that Congress has done so in a
bipartisan way for the last uh for the
last couple of decades right if you
think about the three times where
Democrats came together with Republicans
to lift to deal with the debt ceiling
this is how we believe it's their
constitutional Duty we do not believe
that the full credit and Faith and
Credit of of our nation should be held
hostage we've been very clear on that
there's no negotiation that we will be
having on that particular issue because
it is something that Congress needs to
deal with so I don't have anything more
to share on that we are waiting we're
waiting for house Congressional members
to put forth a budget the president did
that he showed his values he showed what
how he sees the fiscal responsibility of
of uh of the president as we move
forward and to show and be really
transparent to the American people we're
waiting for uh we're waiting for house
members to do the same house Republican
members to do the same is the White
House open to a short-term increase what
I'm saying is we've been very clear that
Congress needs to deal with this issue
as they have done in the last
Administration three times
any sort of reaction from the white
house uh to this liberal judge winning
in the Supreme Court election in
Wisconsin just broadly speaking does the
White House see this as voters casting
their ballots in support of abortion
access and a sign of things to come
heading into 2024. yeah so more broadly
time and time again the American people
have shown their Resolute support for
Reproductive freedom in our democracy
and last night was no different we saw
that clearly after the midterm elections
that every opportunity following the
Supreme Court's decision to overturn Roe
v Wade from Kansas battle initiative in
August and to the Clean Sweep of five
abortion ballot initiatives I just
mentioned in November two two Virginia's
a special election in in January two
last night 2 to last night's elections
in Wisconsin the message from voters has
been clear Americans want the freedom to
make reproductive Health Care decisions
without government interference they
have been very clear about that yet
though you see Republican elected
officials are more committed than ever
to attack those fundamental freedoms
that Americans should have and look you
have Republican officials in Florida
North Carolina and Nebraska are
attempting to pass extreme abortion
bills you have in Congress where we've
seen three National Abortion bills come
out this year on on uh from from
republicans in Congress and so look we
believe that it is important for
Americans to have their freedom
including their right to make a decision
of women to have the right to make a
decision on their own on their own
health care and so the this is the this
is an Administration that's going to
continue to fight for uh fight for those
freedoms
different race the Mayoral race in
Chicago does the White House feel like
there are any lessons for Democrats
based on the results of that race uh
particularly in terms of how the party
should talk about and discuss issues
so I'm not gonna I'm limited in what
what I can say as it looks uh forward to
24 any uh future elections what I can
speak to and as we've done many times
here speak to the president's record he
believes that we should fund the police
and give law enforcement the resources
they need for Effective accountability
and community policing that is something
that the president has been very vocal
about and has taken action on that's why
he supported again the cops program and
he signed the American Rescue plan which
had 350 million dollars billion dollars
to local governments to keep cops on the
beat so the president has been very
clear about this and in his support in
making sure that American families and
communities are protected and feel safe
and he's going to continue to do that
work but not going to dive into any
specifics on how politically to move
forward especially as we get into 2024.
yeah on that though I hear you being a
little more laudatory in terms of the
results in Wisconsin versus and Mr
Johnson's win last night oh I I was
asked specifically about crime and how
we move forward on crime does he make of
Mr Johnson yeah well okay that was not
the question that I got asked I got
specifically asked about crime look I
can say this uh the president is uh
sends his congratulations uh to Chicago
mayor elect Brandon Johnson the
president looks forward to working with
him uh to deliver for the people of
Chicago and uh look you know what I can
say is this uh the mayor elect Johnson
is a former teacher and a union
organizer his victory is a testament to
the strength and organizing power of our
Educators and that's something that we
saw uh yesterday
um and so I'll just leave it there but
no regarding yesterday and had the
president learn about all this you
telling us that he only learned about
this through Staffing or did he consume
any of this as a news concern I could
tell you this here's what I can tell you
is that the president uh was focused on
working on behalf of the American people
he met with his senior advisors his
senior team uh yesterday uh and in the
Oval Office that's that's what he was
continuing to do throughout the day and
uh and that's kind of how he's moving
forward that's what he's going to pay
attention to and you saw that you saw
that in Minnesota this week his focus on
on chips and science act how we're
bringing manufacturing back uh to uh to
this country creating more than eight
hundred thousand jobs that is something
that the president is going to continue
to focus how do we build an economy that
leaves no one behind so that's what the
president is doing I've been very clear
about that that's going to be his Focus
he's not focused uh on on this
indictment that's not what our focus is
on that's something that is an ongoing
case we will let others deal with that
our focus is what the president was
elected to do is make sure that we
deliver for the American public just
real quick not a question but a request
falling over Mary's question about who's
going with the president from the
fighting
family in The Wider Clan can we get
clarification at some point in the
process of that of exactly how this is
paid for you there have been questions
in the past about when he travels with
family or the people who are staying
here about how that is handled yeah and
we're not doing it any differently than
other families who have uh have been in
the White House who have held this held
office and and so you know we'll share
more when we have more to share on who's
going to be traveling with him I don't
have that information so don't want to
get ahead of that but of course the
president is a president that follows
the law and does uh does does these
types of things in the appropriate
fashion appropriate way
Pickering um you mentioned the president
Trump in Minnesota this week he had a
meeting yesterday on artificial
intelligence uh he said he's looking
forward to this trip to Ireland as well
in any other news environment these
might be stories that are really driving
uh both national and local headlines but
as the questions that you've got
yesterday indicate there's one other
story really dominating the news right
now can you talk about the White House's
strategy to make sure the president's
message is getting through to the
American people
president the former president's legal
trolls are likely not to go away at all
this year is there concern that this
will take away from the president's
ability to communicate that message
session well we've been very clear I
here at the podium yesterday as you just
mentioned and today we've been very
clear what our focus is on I actually
got questions on AI a few questions on
AI yesterday that we were able to answer
and speak to from the podium look our
focus is going to continue to be the
American people what you all cover is up
to to all of you but we're going to do
our best to stay the course to talk
about the issues that matter right we
think about the economy Americans really
care about the economy they want to hear
how the president is going to lower
continue to lower costs for them and
that's what we're going to continue to
talk about and so
that doesn't change anything we talked
about AI we went to Minnesota to talk
about chips and science like a very
historic piece of legislation that's
going to make a difference in creating
good paying jobs and bringing jobs back
here to to this country and so again
things that we're not going to stop to
talk about these critically important
issues that the American people really
want to hear from this President about
so we're just going to stay the course
that's our Focus okay thank you uh today
marks one week since the Wall Street
journals evidence Christian which was
detained by Russia secretary blinken
said today he has no doubt that Evan was
wrongfully detained if that's the case
then what's the hold up in making a
formal determination can you provide
more clarity on timing and he also said
in those very remarks that there's a
process right there's a process that's
underway uh and uh and so you know we
have to let the Secretary of State the
secretary of the department uh do there
the Secretary of State Department do
their uh do their job here wrongfully
detention determinations again are made
by them and the secretary of state has
said that while there is still a formal
process that needs to play out he has no
doubt on this one right and so I think
that says everything that you need to
know their commitment the priority uh
that that he has to uh to make sure that
uh that we do everything that we can for
Evan and also make sure that we bring
Paul Whalen home why hasn't President
Biden spoken directly to Evans family
does he have any plans to meet with them
as he did with the families of Brittany
brighter and Paul Newman last fall so
look uh this case is a priority to the
president as I mentioned yesterday I
don't have any calls to read out but I
will say that uh you know that that our
our thoughts are with Evan's family and
again this is a priority for uh for this
for this President I'll give you a
little bit of an update yesterday
Ambassador Linda Thomas Greenfield U.S
representative of the United Nations as
you all know spoke with her counterpart
uh today
um and uh ambassador nebenzia to
announce to to once again convey the
United States gave grave concern about
his attention and call for his immediate
release and so again the department and
I said this yesterday Department of
State continues to uh to seek counselor
access to Evan the U.S embassy in Moscow
has not yet received any approval for
counselor access despite repeated
requests it will likely take some time
so a couple of days before we have
access but again this is a this is a
priority uh for this President uh and uh
and we're going to uh be steadfast of
that you heard from the secretary
himself uh say uh say no doubt in his
mind which I think tells you everything
that you need to know
thanks Corinne yesterday uh your office
put out word that the president would
not be attending the king's coronation
King Charles and that the first lady
would be going on behalf of the United
States uh can you explain the decision
and why the president decided that he
would not go as Head of State on behalf
of you so let me just first say and um
the president had about a 25-minute
30-minute call with the king king uh
King King Charles III and during which
he congratulated the king I think we put
that out last night as upcoming
coronation and they have a very friendly
conversation they have a a good
relationship with the King he talked
about uh how he enjoyed meeting visiting
uh the queen I should say back in 2021
he and the first lady at Windsor and he
hoped to visit again soon actually
during that call the king offered for
him to come and do a state in a state
visit which which uh the president
accepted and uh and so they will see
each other again very soon and uh I'll
just leave it there but again they have
a very very good relationship there are
many things that they both care about
key shared values key shared issues that
they want to continue to discuss like
climate change and that conversation
will continue and there will be a visit
in the near future any sense whether
that state visit might happen I don't I
don't have a timeline at this time don't
I can't say if it when it will be but
the president was uh was appreciative of
the offer by the king and looks forward
to to that state visit
look forward to that question will the
president beat with King Charles when
he's in the United Kingdom next week or
the Prime Minister uh look I will have
more to share on who he's going to be
meeting with I just don't have anything
to to share at this time another
question complete there was a study
today that was released by the former
Bureau of Labor Statistics director
showing that Americans are working fewer
hours is there any concerns that that
could add pressure to the job market and
the fed's efforts to bring down
inflation well I'm not going to talk to
the fed's efforts uh their monetary
policy and that's something that we're
going to do here from here the president
has been very clear we want to give them
the space to have their independence so
not going to speak to any actions or
potential actions that they might take
as far as the report that's the first
time I'm hearing about this I would need
to connect with our economics team here
but look the president we have talked
about how the economy uh the president's
policy when it relates to the economy is
working right we see we see uh created
jobs the president under his economic
plan has created jobs to more than 12
million jobs we saw we saw 300 000 jobs
that we create we created just last
month we saw we see unemployment that is
at a historic low at 3.6 percent and so
we're continuing to see a plan that
doesn't leave anybody behind and make
sure that we're building an economy from
the bottom up middle out as far as that
report I would have to connect with the
economic team
uh excuse me thank you
um on the Wisconsin election
um what I mean I guess I'm curious about
what the president's role is on abortion
the VP is obviously taking kind of a
lead and speaking out on it but what is
the president's role I mean we haven't
really seen him take the issue on the
road for example uh meeting with
stakeholders kind of what what kind of
what position is he playing in this well
if you look at what the administration
has done we've taken historic action
we've taken a historic action because of
the president uh leading that after
effort asking his administration to
figure out what other ways that we can
we can move forward in to make sure that
there is access to reproductive health
care and so the president has taken a
whole government approach through his
reproductive Health Care task force he
put that together right to protect
women's access to productive health care
and he signs uh two executive orders to
protect a woman's right to travel to
receive reproductive Health Care
strengthen privacy measures and address
discrimination in in care this is
something that the president has taken
very seriously along with the vice
president but what we're seeing on the
other side is Republicans doing
everything in their power to make sure
that reproductive care is not available
to women when you see these National
bands when you see these uh these types
of draconian pieces of legislation
across the country that is not something
the American people want to see we know
this by just looking at the midterms I
just laid out all of the all of the the
the the different special elections that
we saw and issue based elections that we
saw just last year where the American
people spoke very loudly they want their
freedoms they want the opportunity to
decide uh what what they should do what
their decision when it comes to Health
Care
can ask regarding Beijing uh and the
pardon me the meeting between McCarthy
and the Taiwan president has uh what
kind of conversation has the White House
been having with Beijing if any just to
kind of dissuade uh any potential uh
violence or any type of you know
response to me so our channels of
communications are open and we have had
a consistent message that has
urged restraint and in recent days we
have conveyed directly to the Chinese at
high levels that escalation is uncalled
for uh and uh and so we'll continue to
keep those channels of conversations
open
I'm on the violence in Jerusalem uh
what's the White House's response to
that and can you talk about any
conversations going on on
that so on the violence that we saw uh
very recently um at least starting with
the mosque we remain extremely concerned
by the continuing violence and we urge
all sides to avoid further escalation it
is imperative now more than ever that
Israelis and Palestinians were together
to de-escalate tensions and restore calm
and uh look you know and that's what
you've been hearing from this President
and from this Administration privately
and publicly for over the past six weeks
and uh and again we're going to continue
to do that again privately and publicly
thank you Queen senor
hello
um there seem to be a bit of a mix-up
when I was messaging mixed up on what
was going on about the invitation to LSU
the basketball team
from LSU uh but it seems that the star
Angel Reese has said that she will not
be coming and the team won't be coming I
think that was even after the White
House
cleared off this mix-up about whether
the runners-up will also be invited can
you pure it up so if the president and
the first lady have expressed their uh
their very much how how they're looking
forward to celebrating the LSU Tigers
and also uh the University of
Connecticut the men's basketball team
the Huskies right here at the White
House continuing a long tradition that
we have had here celebrating a White
House tradition that we have had for
celebrating the championship so we look
forward to uh to welcoming them LSU
Tigers and also the Yukon huskies and
that is uh that is something that we are
are we are again looking forward to to
having as far as you know that coming uh
the Tigers well as you as you know the
president put out uh put out a statement
inviting them I don't have anything
further to share on that but again we're
looking forward to to uh to celebrating
both teams uh here at the Yukon huskies
and also the LSU Tigers
thank you uh Twitter labeled national
public radio as a government influenced
entity
putting NPR in the same category as
Russia today or Chinese media do you
have a comment yeah so social media
companies make their own independent
decisions about content rules so I won't
comment on Twitter's rules but what I
will say uh more broadly I'll say
there's no doubt of the independence of
NPR's journalists and it has been if
you've ever been on the receiving end of
their of their questions you know this
you know that they have their
independence in journalism NPR
journalists work digitally to hold
public officials accountable and inform
the American people the hard-hitting
independence nature of their coverage
speaks speaks for itself and so I'll
leave it there okay Michael about a week
ago the governor of Idaho signed a bill
into law authorizing the use of firing
squads against penalty
uh this nurse Idaho is the fifth state
to legalize the use of firing squads do
you have a comment or does the
administration have a position on this
message I haven't talked to our team
about that particular law I would have
to look into it before I can speak about
it from here and so I'll just leave it
there and we'll get back to you on that
particular question
[Music]
or the child Court in Mississippi
Senator Hyde Smith had said she would
support the nominee I know you're
sticking with your nominee what do you
hope to see Senator Durbin do next
so
um look when you think about our nominee
it's a chosen a Biden was very proud to
choose someone who is uh deeply
qualified uh dedicated to our
Constitution and who received the
backing of Republicans and Democrats in
Mississippi
and he is a duly elected district
attorney is clearly trusted by many of
us many of Senator Hyde Smith's
constituents and keep to keep them safe
and ensure that Justice is done so it is
unfortunate sadly that uh regardless of
being duly consulted consulted well in
advance and despite Senator wicker
returning a blue slip Senator Hyde Smith
is preventing the people of Mississippi
from having a judge in place in a timely
fashion to uphold the rule of law for
her state so uh you know furthermore
Senator Hyde Smith never raised these
issues before today over the course of
months including when she met with Mr
column several several weeks ago and
never ever suggested any alternative
candidates and so look to your point
we're going to stick with our with our
we think our highly qualified candidate
and uh and I'll leave it there
leave that um
excuse me should be required for trial
court nominees or would you want the
senator to move forward with this one so
look I I'll leave it to uh to Congress
and I'll leave it to the Senate to
figure that piece out but what I can say
is we believe uh Scott is a thoroughly
qualified candidate uh and uh and we're
gonna leave it there and continue to
support his candidacy his nomination
thank you
thank you Kareem first on the news of
the day does it bug President Biden when
former presidents suck up all the oxygen
what's important to the president is to
continue to focus on the American people
that is what's important to the
president so he's good to lay low for a
couple news Cycles so look here's the
thing here's the thing Peter and
and two we will
lose the fact that that this is a
president that has been able to
get historic pieces of legislation done
when you think about the infrastructure
legislation something that you know we
heard many many times during the last
Administration infrastructure week
infrastructure week guess what this
president was able to do who's able to
bring both both sides together to get
this done and now we have we're seeing
investments in the country rebuilding in
the country that we haven't seen in 70
years that's what the president cares
about he cares about the fact that
Medicare is now able uh to uh to to work
you know talk to Big Pharma to lower uh
Linda negotiate and lower cost that's
what the president cares about what he
wants to see is how do we build on his
economic policies economic plan that
week that has been able to turn this
country around from when he first walked
in from uh from you know what we saw
happen in the last Administration
basically a mess when it came to the
economy when it came to dealing with
covid so black the president wants to do
is to build on that and that's his Focus
he wakes up every morning thinking about
the American people he goes to bed every
night thinking about the American people
okay on the Taiwan President visit if
China tries to take over Taiwan is
President Biden still committed to
putting U.S boots on the ground in
Taiwan we've answered this question
multiple times I'm not I'm not I'm I
don't have anything else to share okay
and then on the China spycraft
why did President Biden say about the
China spycraft in February we were able
to protect sensitive sites against
election
if that's not true I'm not going to go
into a dive into any reporting uh that's
not something I'm going to do I'm not
going to confirm any reporting look we
knew the flight reporting the dni said
today that the US does not appear to
have provided critical new insights to
the People's Republic of China so is it
they didn't provide any new critical
insights or
they didn't get anything I would refer
you to the odni if you have specific
questions on their reporting what I can
tell you from here and what we have said
many times is that we knew the flight
path of the balloon before it crossed
the United States we took precautions in
advance to ensure that it didn't get
sensitive information and when it when
it when it comes to technology like this
balloon it has limited additive value
compared to other means of intelligent
collection and we have said that and the
bottom line is this is the
administration that identified the
problem and took action
I think it's green how is the White
House preparing for the medication
abortion rulings and who's involved in
leading those efforts so um again I'm
going to be very careful as that is uh
as we're still waiting for uh the ruling
to to come forth we have been talking
internally uh how we would move forward
if that were this unprecedented action
was taken and so just don't have
anything more to share on that but again
uh this is something if it were to
happen would be unprecedented uh I don't
want to get into specifics around
ongoing litigation I'll say this that
this is about the fda's authority to
make its independent evidence-based
decision on drugs decision on what
medication can be used in our country
should not be determined in a court they
should be determined based on their
Safety Science and the data and so the
bottom line when you think about uh uh
mifa Presto this is something that's
been this is a drug that's been around
for two decades this is a drug that is
that is used 60 other countries again
this is something that is an FDA
Authority and so not going to get
involved I'm not going to go into into
more deeply about the specific case but
yes it would be unprecedented but is the
White House concerned that you could
have two different federal courts with
two different rulings and that this
could then wind up before The Supreme
Court which last summer of returned
abortion rights so look we're going to
prepare for all the different range of
scenarios that's what I can promise the
American people that's what I can say uh
here to ensure that they accessed this
drug for women that women have this
access to this drug so we're again we're
going to prepare for and for the
different scenarios I'm just not going
to get ahead of that
thanks green if I could follow up Summit
coordination uh aside from the readout
that the president had with the King can
you just explain why it's not the
president himself going to represent the
U.S and the first lady instead look the
president is looking forward he had a
great conversation has a good
relationship with uh King Charles III
and they've they as you know they've met
before and there's a lot of shared
interests the shared values of issues
that they want to discuss and they will
continue to discuss one of them being
climate change and and at some time in
the future the King invited the
president for a state visit he accepted
and that will happen just don't have
anything further to share on that okay
thanks crane are you concerned that the
British people might see this as a snub
that the president's not going I know
presidents haven't gone in the past but
now we have airplanes and much more
modern technology that makes these kinds
of trips easy to do and what's to say
about the special relationship no they
should not say it at a snub not at all
again the president has a good
relationship with the King they had a a
friendly conversation and I will leave
it at that it is not a snub okay yeah
last year when the president was gave
his democracy speech uh the networks all
said they wouldn't air it because it was
political some of the same networks last
night aired a political speech uh by the
president's opponent is that something
you'd now see as a precedent the next
time you want air time I'm not going to
speak to that okay
uh thank you
um former vice president Pence said that
if the shooter who killed six people uh
in that Christian School in Tennessee
was motivated motivated by a hatred
towards Christians that the crime should
be categorized as a hate crime I'm
wondering what the president thinks of
that kind of designation is not for us
to decide and then today Indiana just uh
banned puberty blockers hormone
therapies and gender transition
surgeries for minors I'm wondering what
the president's reaction is to the
Indiana Governor signing that bill into
law and does the president have a
position on at what age these kinds of
therapies and surgeries are appropriate
that's something for a child and and
their parents to decide it's not
something we believe should be decided
by by legislators so I'll leave it there
but um
well you know in the past couple of
months we have seen a record number of
lgbtqi bills
anti-lgbtqi uh bills more than 600 of
them have been filed in state houses uh
and a significant number of them have
been anti-trans
bills and uh you know targeted at Youth
and this is a president that has said
that when these uh these are some of the
bravest people uh he knows and but no
one should have to be brave just to be
themselves
and so this is a president that has come
been committed to this community that
has been committed to our to our kids uh
in the trans Community to trans Youth
and he's going to continue to fight for
them uh but uh but again I'm just uh
gonna leave it there two
um two questions on uh legal matters so
I know you may not be able to speak to
them too much uh first
uh the Attorney General of Texas is
apparently going to court trying to
block implementation of the Omnibus on
the ground that there wasn't a quorum
present of the members of the House of
Representatives uh in person when that
was passed does the administration yet
have a view on on the legality of the
the Omnibus and and what the Texas
Attorney General is
suggesting I'm just not going to comment
to that and what's their second question
the second one is uh there was a ruling
about uh preventative Services in the
Affordable Care Act and the the and what
is the message to insurers and providers
uh with that
ruling having been made and obviously
appeals coming but but right now what's
the message to Providers and to
insurance companies about the the court
blocking that the Texas ACA yes so look
the president is glad to see that doj is
appealing this decision which blocks a
key provision of the Affordable Care Act
that has ensured free access to
preventive health care for 150 million
Americans this case isn't yet another
attack on the Affordable Care Act which
has been around as you know for 13 years
and and survived has survived three
challenges before The Supreme Court the
administration is going to continue to
improve to fight to improve health care
as we have seen him do the last two
years and make it more affordable for
hard-working Working Families that is
something that the president has been
committed to and uh and so we're going
to continue to do that especially as it
faces attacks by special interests
King's Marine well in Florida Governor
Ron desantisani a concealed permitless
concealed weapon law I Know You released
a statement but does the White House
feel that when laws like this are passed
in States like Florida that it
undermines the work is doing to address
the of the nation's gun epidemic so we
think it's shameful it's certainly
shameful and tragic especially after a
school shooting that's what that's what
the Florida governor decided to do
and again we spoke we spoke about this
last week and if you think about this
bill this law it eliminates the need to
get a license to carry a concealed
weapon this is what was signed after we
heard what occurred in Nashville
Tennessee after we heard three kids in
three three administrators were you know
were murdered and so look what we think
it's the opposite of common uh Common
Sense gun safety which we know majority
of Americans want to see this is not
what they want to see they want to wait
to see a way in a common sense way on
how we're going to protect our
communities how we're going to protect
our kids and how we're going to protect
Americans and so uh you know too many
lives have been ripped apart too many
lives have been taken and the president
is going to continue to call on Congress
to move forward with the assault weapons
ban he's going to be very clear about
that the high capacity magazines require
safe storage of firearms eliminate gun
manufacturers immune from liability and
require background checks for all gun
sales and for State officials to take
action on the state level as well but it
is incredibly shameful to see what was
done in Florida and uh and again it's
just unfortunate after a tragic event
letter to speaker McCarthy and
Congressional members of both parties
wanting them do not meet with the
Taiwanese president what is the White
House response to China's intimidation
to the U.S politicians on the U.S soil
uh what are you going to do about it and
the second one is that uh how does the
administration see Beijing tomorrow
hosting Iran and Saudi Arabia foreign
ministers in their past towards the
normalization look I've spoken to your
first question before uh just moments
ago I spoke to it yesterday I just spoke
to it moments ago and I also also
highlighted what secretary blinken said
today in Belgium and again we've been
very clear there's no reason for Beijing
to use this to Transit that has been
done many times before this particular
President of Taiwan has done it six
times before it is an unofficial visit
it is a private visit and it should not
be used to for any kind of escalation
overreaction and we've been very clear
about that I talked about how we've had
conversations open line of wanting to
keep those open line of communications
with beijings and we've had Direct
conversations about this and uh and and
lastly I'll just say congress is a
separate and co-equal branch of
government and uh you know and so any
specifics about that particular meeting
I would certainly refer you uh to this
to the speaker's office go ahead
Administration considering declaring
access to abortion of Public Health
Emergency and if so what might that look
like I don't have anything to share on
on that piece I know I've been asked
we've been asked many times about that I
just don't have anything to do
additionally
we'll see you tomorrow guys have a good
day